Please welcome to the stage director,
Catherine Hardwicke,
actress Toni Collette and Jacqueline
Bisset and screenwriter and marina back.
So how are you all doing? Pretty well.
Thanks. Yeah, thanks siding. Yeah,
glad to be here. And the brain test. Yeah.
So how did you all get
attached to the project? Uh
Oh, everyone's going to be okay with you.
It started, it did, it did, yes. Um,
wrote the screenplay and our director,
our director,
I'll produce a Chris Simon
had met Catherine at a film
festival and I think in
London and a few years back.
Yeah.
And when we were looking for a director
for our, for our film, he said,
I know just the person. And Luckily
Catherine said yes. So that's,
that's the short form. And Tony was
a mango tree and then there was,
there was a mango tree in there somewhere.
And then Tony was involved with
the project right from the start,
from way back when.
And then actually initially I was offered
to play the role of Jess and somebody
else was playing Millie and that's
somebody else dropped out. Yeah.
And it went through a few
different Millie's that
nobody was sticking and yeah,
well she just demanded that she was
going to be milling, let's be honest.
Eventually
to me was I was doing a play on Broadway
and I was playing was last year,
the realistic Joneses. And I was
playing a very capable, grounded,
solid person who holds the world together
for lots of other people. And, um,
I was frustrated at the last, Millie had
fallen out of my friends, said, well,
tell me about film because
I was so eager to make it.
I was attached to it for several years
and I just think it's so special. Um,
and when I explained to the characters
and their dynamic, she was like,
why would you play that role again?
I've just watched you do it on stage,
you need to be the hot mess.
And so that's when I told the guy.
And then as soon as that happened,
actually everything lined up and fell
into place and it obviously it was meant
to happen this way.
So you felt as if, um, the
characters were more or less,
you kind of got attached right
away when it comes to that,
or at least when you were introduced that,
oh, when I read it, it was
almost like I had no choice.
It was like a soul connection to this
story and I just fell in love with it and
I had to do it. It was an, it
was an, it was a need more. Yeah.
Oh, it was, it was, you know, Tony's kind
of passion for it was fantastic. Was it?
At times when you kind of think what,
you know, this is, this is, you know,
is the long haul. And then, and
then when Catherine also, you know,
join that was just, you know,
then it, then it really took off.
I did find out something last night from
one of Tony's longtime best friends, uh,
speaking about the hot. Yeah. It kind
of embarrassed. Okay. Because Tony,
you know, said, okay, you should play the
hotness, will your best, do your best.
Friends told me that she thought
this part was the closest to you.
Have any parts you've ever played?
I actually,
I think I'm a combination of both.
Yeah.
That could be embarrassing,
but it nearly is great.
Did you guys like Millie
or what'd you get to say?
I mean she's horribly flawed and
has made some very bad decisions,
but she's very charismatic and the life
of the party who doesn't admire that?
Mm hmm.
What I found interesting with when he
came to both the cast and the setting was
that it was all set in England where
the Dewberry Morris character as, um,
the American that comes through.
Um, were you thinking about, uh,
what the story would be if it
weren't said in England? Yeah,
well, I'm, Lorena, uh, lives in England,
wrote it for London. So it was a very,
I think it's,
I mean it's kind of odd to me with,
I mean that question luckily hasn't come
up too much in terms of how, how can,
how come,
how come she's an American from that
because it's so kind of multicultural
London as it has our most large
cities and my kids are at school with,
with kids from all over the world.
And so it didn't seem that strange to
me too. You know, too when we were,
you know, when, when Tony, where
did that role yeah, exactly. For,
that's a bit of that to be the case.
Um,
and actually I think it really brought
something to it. So it was, it was good.
Hmm.
And speaking of the script,
I heard that the film was based
off your radio play goodbye.
First podcasts on the BBC four.
Um, and I guess Catherine, you, uh,
I don't know if you heard
of a can buy prior to this?
Um, no I hadn't and I never actually
heard that. It's not actually,
it's actually not based on that. That's
a bit, no, that's that, that is, no,
it's kind of Nice to be able to just say
that it's not, that was a project that,
that, that preceded them is in a
very different form with, uh, and,
and written with a different impetus. And
this, this, this sort of started a fresh,
um, although it's a same subject matter
because like lots of writers and you,
you keep going back to the same
subject matter. But it, yeah,
it touched on the same thing. It
was very different project. Yeah.
And he also spoke, uh, mentioned
that you wrote this, uh,
to be sending England to be
put there. Um, how exactly,
how did you like filming around England?
How was that for every
freaking awesome. I didn't
want to leave the city.
It's such an ex culturally exciting city.
It's changed so much after
him over the years. Actually
I used to be an architect. I
loved it. The old architecture,
the new architecture adds this
great energy. Like that combination,
the part of the world where
they shot it to that the house,
her house with her husband
was down near, um, the,
what's it call that big round thing that
goes around the London, the London eye.
Yeah. Great area. Yeah.
Really, really cool.
And it was fantastic to see it through
your eyes as well actually to see it on
the shot through Caspian size because
it's just the place that I'm in every day
that I walked through that I,
you know,
and then it's kind of
just seeing the kind of,
the breadth of vision that you had
was really, really cool. I love that.
I didn't want it to be like a nodding hill
where people live in those terrorists,
townhouse walk ups that we've
seen in a million movies.
So that's why we tried to find it.
We down that Great Gina, which was
a forge brick building that this new
architecture would come in and put all
these ramps and made it really fun.
Lots of different levels and yeah,
we love shooting in London.
We want to go back.
Any noteworthy points from
the entire shoot that you had?
What a broad question.
Oh,
do you want to talk about it?
Okay.
I've got a very determined
to bladder tack.
Tony kept saying, well,
when we're doing that tax,
the are we going to stop in a
minute because I'm really busting.
And they said we can't find a place
to stop. They kept saying that.
So Drew's addicted to this ice to teach
her drinking out of those styrofoam.
Very not very green at all. Um, Styrofoam
milkshake cups. So she'd finished,
offered it to me and I took her up on
the offer and we had coats like trying to
hide Tony like right in the middle of
downtown landlording, those black taxi,
very roomy. And I didn't feel
it once I filled it twice
go.
There wasn't a crew member when I did
the [inaudible] window that people drove
by like
healthy green tea.
It's no great.
Maybe that's not the anecdote type it in.
And
it was actually,
I'd have to say the moment that the scene
where not giving anything away because
you didn't seen it, right? Yeah. Okay.
Where Tony head is shaped there was,
I mean that for me was really amazing
because we did that really early on,
didn't we?
In the shoot days.
I felt so responsible as it could be shit.
And Tony Shaved her head and you know,
we did it like nobody likes it and
anything that was real, that was real,
that was not liked.
And that actress Frances de la tour,
she was so brave. She did was bring
shady named one of the heads right.
She practiced Paul Paul yet the second 18
she was going so fast. I was like, could
you slow down Francis Cause I couldn't,
we could barely even see it on camera.
She was brave.
Has anybody here ever shaved her
head? It feels great. Cherry red.
In fact,
I did it until about mid college.
Now you're doing it don't look
like recently you haven't,
it's very refreshing once you shave your
head and then everyone kind of wants to
touch it. It's like, oh you're a port.
No, you got stop touching you. So yeah,
although that's what she,
I think she's done it before. You've
done it before. I haven't done it before.
Everyone was freaking out.
They gave the vote cause you're
like calm my nerves. But I'd
done it five times. Five Times.
When did you do before I,
when I turned 25, I was in
Mexico. I had a lot of Tequila
speaking true to the
character that might've been
a slightly merely my bit. Um,
she would never shave her head,
you know, for other purposes. Um,
I did it for Peter Greenaway film,
actually called eight and a half women.
I did it three days
after meeting my husband.
I guess I was that one meant to
challenge. Wow. He, he was like,
yeah.
And I did it for,
a friend of mine is a designer
and I modeled in a show of hers.
We'd been in Tibet together and so I was
attempting to get kind of the look of
it. So just for a special treat to
Google, we're going to do it again today.
We know
you love your hair.
Cool.
Yeah.
Unless, unless she does it, she
plans to do it again. Just, um,
I guess that's kind of cool.
If you were to plan to do it again,
I've done it five times.
The likelihood of doing it again is high.
I just want to remind everyone
that we do have a mic set up, uh,
on both sides of the stage if you want
to come up and ask some questions. Um,
but I can continue going on with
more questions that I have here.
One interesting part that I found about
the movie was this entire theme of
reckless, this kind of seems to
go rampant throughout the movie.
We saw your character go through
quite a few reckless action.
What with initially with the cancer's
sprinting around because you know,
she didn't get regular checkups and that's
kind of how it started. And you know,
right after the birthday scene where, you
know, just just go to the Moore's. Um,
uh, in particular what I was
kind of curious about, um,
how'd you approach this
entire reckless attitude?
I don't know if you projected
anything personally.
I mean, it was all in the script.
We had the brilliant gifted,
this beautiful script and their story.
And the thing that I love about, um,
not just my character, but all the
characters, they're so fully realized.
Sometimes you watch a movie in the
lead characters seem to be, you know,
like real people you can relate to
and then the other character's somehow
becomes secondary.
And I think the film suffers on the whole
because then you're not invested and
you don't believe in the real world.
This is a fleet realized rich,
dense life shared life that
these people are living.
And I love the complexity
of all the characters.
I love that my character is completely
flawed and he's kind of, you know,
maniacal at times and outrageous and
completely selfish and narcissistic and it
does make some bad decisions,
but she's also incredibly charismatic
and that in itself is basically lets lets
her get away with murder
where she takes advantage of
any particular point.
Why it kind of seems as if reckless,
which was such a strong
theme in the movie.
I think, I mean, just the,
for me, I, I, you know,
I'm very much the strong opinion that
people don't get diagnosed with cancer and
study to become saints and
heroes. I think it, I think they,
they the best they can.
And, and, and given certainly the women
that we all spoke to, you know, the, the,
the research that we did and
the, and the, and the, you know,
everybody drawing on experience,
you're just trying to get on
with your life and you kind of,
you have cancer for a while and have
one kind of helps look after you.
And then particularly what we were
looking at was diagnosed in younger women.
You have to get up and do
the school run and you know,
clean the house and do all the things and
the kind of the help slowly falls away
because people can't sustain it. Nobody
can sustain it. And that's about all,
you know, you're not sort of, you're not
constipated. And I think that was what we,
we sort of wanted to look at.
It was just how life goes on and
how that impacts on everyone.
And so that's why all the characters
had their own viewpoints and we're all
trying to be good and we're all trying
to kind of help everyone get through it.
But everybody kept making it difficult.
Uh, you know, at every turn and you know,
Catherine sort of grasping that and
giving each character that their real
identity filmic identity was, was
fantastic. So yeah, it was about them.
It's all about complexity wasn't, it was
about how hard it is. You know, I'm for,
I'm for Jaclyn's character.
Oh,
I'd love to hear more about that because
like as a mother, I'm hearing this,
it's an interesting perspective to
get. Well, I haven't gotten dota like,
yeah, Millie, what a handful. I mean,
the fact that I,
my character was away a lot,
set up a situation where she resented
me, I think, and was annoyed with me,
completely annoyed with me that she
was, she didn't, I don't think, oh,
near the very end when she says,
Mommy, you've still got it.
Got Her almost into the taxi.
Um, but my only salvation,
but of all the rest of the time,
I think she knows that her daughter
thinks she's just really just, you know,
I don't even think she has respect
for my daughter actually. Do,
do you think she had respect
from her daughter? No.
No, not really. Not really.
No. But I think I have my
character had respect. Really.
Yeah. Part of, I mean when you,
I think when you facing at your own
potential mortality, that's very, uh,
kind of lonely solo journey
that you have to take.
And I think a lot of the things that
Millie learns, I mean, what I love you,
she doesn't change that much, but she
does learn to appreciate what she has.
And what she has is a Ford mother and she
has is flawed and probably see as much
of herself in her mom. Um,
they're two peas in a pod.
It kind of takes one to know.
I thought, well, I thought
Miranda was adorable in many ways
and then I thought, but then
Millie was the doorbell in many ways too.
If she hadn't been my daughter,
I'd probably want it to hang out with her,
you know?
But I couldn't get in there
between she and drew. I mean,
there was just no space for Ms.
Miranda for between those two.
When she goes to got sick. I mean, apart
from the fact it was in total shock.
I don't think she knew where to start to,
how to get in because they would,
they'd went to each other.
These other two friends,
they went to each other for
comfort on every level, you
know, pretty much. And um,
I mean there were even more,
there were almost more engrossed in
their friendship than they were in their
husbands in a way. They were sort
of, um, just very, very close.
And uh, I've been in the
scene when I visited, um,
Millie in the hospital and then
her friends arrive, you know,
and she's much happier
to see the friends come.
Then she has to see me ride
with my puree of God knows what,
what was it? I can't remember what it
was, but there again, you know, she,
Miranda was like, ah, you
know. Okay, great job.
She was not minding, but she was not
really able to find a place to be.
I think so. I mean, when I was sitting
by the bedside, I remember thinking,
this is so hard for me to sit here and
not take over. I mean, let me Jacqueline,
I mean I would've been,
you know,
I would just before I was
given permission to take over,
cause she says I want
to go to the hospital.
But before that I'm there by the bed and
I'm thinking, oh me, Jacqueline would,
I just would have taken over a
million things. So because I'm very,
we didn't know that
but I had to sit there.
Yes. I had to sit there and
be, you know, be be Miranda,
which was to sit there and fall asleep
and wake up and think God knows what's
going to happen next and she's going
to die or what's going to happen.
It is he looking after her and everything
and is he really looking after and he
gives up to her quickly and he goes
out of the room and then she takes her
charge immediate, she gets five minutes
and she's out the door. She said,
I want to go.
She her husband's word of I'm going to
get the nurse to get to stop you from
wanting to go.
Now let's not tell the whole story.
Whole sticks in the film. No,
but this is going out alive,
right. Or somewhere it's recorded.
It's going into the world. Okay. Well,
I've been the, anyway, so I didn't know.
I thought it was a complicated,
but it was nice. I liked it. And, um,
one thing that was fun, uh, a couple of
times you came and said to me, I think I,
I can't be very nice because these
characters don't seem to like me,
so I don't get to be myself.
My Nice, compassionate itself.
You guys planned to be worse. Yeah. She
wanted to be more prickly and outrageous,
which I loved. If you
got a question. Oh yeah.
Um, first of all, well done.
Everyone knows a beautiful film. Um,
but I also wanted to just really get
to the crux of this movie was the
relationship between, um,
you know, the two girls.
And what I thought was done so beautifully
was that opening scene where you got
us to really buy in to that friendship
and buy into that relationship,
which is where I think a lot of
movies on a similar theme fall short.
So I was wondering two fold.
What was your inspiration? Um,
and also what did you guys do as a
cast to make sure that that happened?
That connection showed on screen?
Uh, when you're talking about the opening,
you're, you're thinking about the,
yeah, exactly. Yeah.
And that's what it was a tell I that
was one of our toughest things to get
together. I think Catherine don't, yeah,
we kind of kept writing and rewriting and
trying to reorganize it and figure out
which bits were going to be crucial
in which bits. We don't need that,
but do you need that? And that was, I mean
that was really, I have to really, again,
defer to Catherine who, who had all the
raw footage and, and, and more and the,
and some of my favorite moments in that,
that is the kind of girls
running in the little,
just this kind of texture or moments
which made that piece really rise and,
and, and you know, helps
you buy into it. You know,
I really have to hunt the Caspian
sentence of texture and the story and the
commitment to that friendship and
understanding the history. So we worked,
we worked on that one really
hard and we'd kept thinking,
I'm never sure if we've got this.
Yeah. I think in the, you know,
in the end it will as it
was well done. And then, um,
how did we create a bond? I mean, Tony
and drew had barely met each other.
A couple drive bys.
Yeah.
A bunch of mutual friends and we'd
met a couple of times, but we weren't,
we put some crazy reason.
We just never hung out.
I wrote a letter to her kind of
basically talent. It was a love letter,
basically begging her to be a part of
the movie and talking about why I thought
she was right for it,
which is that she emanates such warmth.
She's the ultimate girls go.
And, uh, she's, you know,
if you dreaming of best friend,
there is nobody better. Um,
we would all pick drew,
right? Yeah. And uh,
and I talked about why I thought the
film was important and, and I, and she,
and why I thought it was rare and she
agreed because she loved it and we had
five days of rehearsing together.
I was like praying,
I hope they get alone. He
Must Jay, you really can't.
But we'd already communicated with.
We'd been writing a little and we both
had really great intentions for the
experience.
And I think the fact that we knew we had
friends in common and I knew they loved
her. It kind of just, you know,
it makes you realize you're not gonna
be faced with a crazy person, um,
because they are already in the circle.
Um,
but we just got on like a house on fire.
It could not have been better.
And I think it gives the film something
so real because we kind of just fell in
love with each other as friends and we're
at the end of the movie, we grabbed,
our family's, caught the train to
Paris. We didn't want to let go.
We had a week there and we've had several
holidays together and weed, weed, weed.
I, it's very rare to come away with
a friendship. But I have to say,
I wonder also whether it's
just the material,
the story is so profound and it was such
an amazing experience that perhaps the
two people playing that those parts,
it was inevitable that we're going to be,
honestly, it's just I, you know,
but how fortunate, well, I mean,
I think that you can write, you
can write shorthand, you can write,
you can write kind of banter.
You can,
you can write to two people kind of
acting like they're friends and if it
doesn't fit authentic, you
just see it. You can't,
you really can't kind of fake it. You
can't put those two together. Um, and you,
and you did. And you know, they,
they're, they're great devices as well.
The Fun thing would build on what Lorena
road and then they were just crazy shit
comes out of her mouth and through his
mouth all the time and original like neat,
interesting stuff. That's
like gold. I was like, yes,
back there behind the camera
and say Betty in that, that it,
that they sort of really inhabited those
characters and that friendship became
an authentic one. That was sort of there
on the page and then I was in real life,
ladies and gentlemen. All right.
You have another question here?
Um, yeah, first I was going to say, I
really enjoyed the film. It was beautiful.
Thank you. Um, and then I just wanted
to ask, kind of along that same note,
I thought what the film
did really brilliantly was
infused comedy to scene. So,
you know, I'm on the verge of tears
and then you're kind of laughing.
So I just wanted to know how you found
the balance between that and how you knew,
you know, when you could make it
fun, even though it's, you know,
such a tough subject matter.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
That's really nice. What I think is,
it's basically the way that I see
I see the world and uh, you know,
probably I'm a bit twisted, but, uh, you
know, something, something bad happens,
then I'll probably laugh at it. You know,
it is, it's kind of nervous reaction,
but it's also,
I think life's like that you kind of stuff
comes out and you undercut it all the
time. And that's sort of who I
am. But also I grew up, you know,
I kind of came out of a comedy background
and I was always kind of horrified
that, that, that can kind of comedians.
So pigeonholing and I think some of the
best comedy act as well as some of the
best dramatic actors as well.
And vice versa. You know,
that you find very dramatic actors,
you've got fantastic comic street.
And I think that I really wanted to kind
of bring that to the script and given
it, it's a tough subject. You've
kind of got to go somewhere with it.
That takes me in and out of that.
And when you have a tragic
moment to undercut it with,
it was not like a deliberate, it
wasn't mathematical, but it was,
it just always felt right
to try and offer some,
and actually there are moments when
you kind of can't do that. And,
and the sort of the beauty of,
particularly towards the ending
where it becomes right to 10,
you just have to calibrate it. And again,
you know, the, the activism and Catherine,
you know, that's, that's that,
that, that genius as well. So,
you know that, thank you. Good day to you.
Thank you.
[inaudible] of the things I loved about
it totally is so exciting because I find
like straight drama or you know,
just bring broad comedies,
both of them equally dry.
I think this film is so lifelike and so
relative because we traverse between all
of those areas and it's, yeah, you
did it so beautifully. Bless you.
When I'm actually,
and again
the women that we spoke to who were going
through this and then they were funny
and they, and they were, you know,
they were kind of urging us to kind of
talk about the more taboo and of the end
of the film kind of relationship,
sex, how it is, you know, the kind of,
the way that your sexuality
becomes so challenged by, by,
by what happens by, by, by
IVF, lung cancer. You know.
So I think it was just in the other
part of the story. So, you know, it was,
I think it felt right to reflect into
reflect the way that the people are
feeling about it. Can I ask a
question? Yes, you can. Did it,
did it occur to you that, that ever, ever
in this version that she might not die?
No, no, no. So it was, I would say
if anyone hasn't yes. Yeah. No,
no, no, no. That was
always, that was always,
obviously we can recut the end and
do a sequel, but, um, but no, it was,
it was sometimes
people do get, yeah, I know. I
know. Yeah. No, no, I know what
you mean. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. No, we don't want to give
this away to everybody. Okay.
All right.
We have another question here.
So moved on so many levels by the film.
Um, the writing, the acting, it was,
I was bawling like a baby for
great. You know, I was happy,
I was sad and it really made me think
about two kind of main relationships in
life. One with a really great
girlfriend and one of a mother.
I have a one year old and it makes
me think about how, you know,
life gets in the way,
work gets in the way,
and just films like these kinds
of make you think like, do you,
do you do something different with your
time to take advantage of that time that
you do have that's outside of work and
outside of kind of daily responsibilities
before something like this happened.
So I just wanted to ask whether as mothers
or I don't know if you guys have kids,
but as mothers or you know,
great friends,
has it made you think differently about
the time that you have on earth and you
know,
before something like this happens?
Well,
I think a lot about this anyway,
but this film for me was incredibly
Cathartic and it took a long time to
separate from it. Uh, so yeah, I do.
I think about it and there are scenes,
particularly there's a scene with young
owner who plays my daughter and the
scene where I'm having a very tough
conversation with her and I just,
I'd get into bed at night to read through
the script and I just could not do it.
There were just some moments in there
that are so kind of intense, but yeah. Uh,
yes, it's, um, it's an it,
I mean it's inevitable on any film you're
working on for it to kind of seep into
your life and for you
to ruminate and ponder.
I love it when people walked out of
the theater and told me that, you know,
they went to call their best
friend or one guy said, hey,
I called my best friend to
bury the hatchet, you know,
that we've got to like be buddies again.
Or people called their friend to go on a
road trip. So I think that's fantastic.
Yes.
Still
want to call the person who
have to tell them exactly,
which just means like for films, it,
it, it opens people up. You know,
this film actually opens
people up. And I, I love that.
That's part of the reason
I want to make movies.
I think also disconnected and numb
and for film to do that and make you
appreciate what you haven't
really pause and think about it.
It's bloody fantastic. Thank you. Thank
you for that. That's really lovely.
I think it has been Cathartic and I think
actually for some of my male friends
who came and I know it's a, yeah, I
know that is because this is sort of a,
it's a trope or a cliche that you know
that men, the expressing of women do.
And I, and I don't think that's true.
Again, my whole thing in the film was not,
not to my stereotypes was to try and go,
you know,
something can talk about the feedings,
you know, till the cows come home,
some income. But um, I
think it has had a quite,
quite a cathartic effect on,
on,
on several men I know who weren't able
to sort of say how they felt about recent
experiences that have been
very challenging for the
mishap, sat in the theater.
And, and just bald. And that was
shopped them. Actually, you know,
one of them had to go home and drink
isotonic drinks. He's like, yeah, yeah.
One Guy told me that he was sitting
there and he started crying.
He didn't want any other guys to see
him cry. So he kind of looked around,
he saw the guy next to him was crying
and he saw the other guy was crying.
Then he saw the cheese Nachos guy was
crying. It's like, oh well whatever.
He said the guy had been eating cheese,
not just,
didn't even think he was watching the
movie and then then he looked over there
and the cheese Nachos
or like getting soggy.
It's kind of unfortunate that there
isn't the male cast here to also speak on
the roles, you know, as, as
everyone's kind of going. Right.
Cause we love the guys in the movie,
didn't you guys like the guys?
They're hot and dimensional and you know.
Cool.
Yeah.
But how did, um, how did you want to
portray the male characters? You know,
watching all these sorts of experiences
that are strong in terms of some sort of
a feminine hit, you know,
having a mastectomy, you know,
I'm dealing with breast cancer
at at least with, with guys.
Well I guess we also have a
chance of getting breast cancer,
but it's not as likely as
girls mastectomies. Probably
a bit more attached to,
um, other women in terms of
something emotive. But how did, uh,
how did you want to portray the men when
it comes to something observed like this
one thing? You know, a lot of times
men feel like they can, they know,
save the day or solve the
problem or be protective.
And it's not very easy when your
enemy is cancer. You know, there's,
that's something that a man can
feel helpless, you know, and they,
they want to be supportive
and these guys are like,
I think they're great man in the movie.
I love these characters and you know,
and Dominic Cooper's character,
Tony's husband, I mean, he's,
he's just like really a great guy and
stands by her even all the bad things.
She was, you know, and
he's a great dad, you know,
which is unexpected when you, you know,
look at other roles at Dominic's played.
I kind of think that I expect him to be
like a bad boy or something like that.
And he really stood up and it was
like, great man. You know, I love that.
And a lot of times we just seen
movies where the men, they,
if their daughter gets
kidnapped, you know, they go
out with a gun and kill yeah.
100 people right there.
Couldn't revenge. But, you know,
that's one way to be a good dad.
You know, there's other ways.
I think so narratively as well.
Potentially the easy thing to do would've
been to have made the husband having
an affair.
And then all this empathy lies squarely
with the person who's going through the
illness. And that did occur to
me at one point as an option.
But, but I, but I, I,
I think it was so much more
challenging and complex and I,
I hope, um, dramatically, uh,
kind of challenging and
satisfying that did that.
It was that it was a character who was,
who was sick because,
and also the character that
Tyson Ritter plays as well.
That how he handled that because of it,
that's going to be a challenging role.
Somebody to be able to pull that off
really. And do you guys like Tyson,
you know him from all American
rejects is pretty good.
Cool. Right? Yeah. And how many women
wouldn't have enough here or would have
to have a guy that could
kind of pull that off?
Oh, he's so deeply likable. So
I, I, you know, I think it was,
yeah, the, I was, I was glad that it
turned out that way, but it wasn't a,
it was an easy choice to make thinking
we're going to go with this one.
What did you guys do with him?
You mean? No, no. The, the,
the, the, the fact that, that,
that the cat, that Tony's character
was the, the, the, you know,
in technical terms of sort of
the transgressor narratively,
and it wasn't the guy that would afraid
that would have placed the sympathy.
There have been a different movie.
Yup.
Can you comment on,
um,
what your thoughts were in trying to
contrast both the relationship with those
two with, with, with uh, Toni
and kit and Tony and ace in the,
what do you think it's, I
mean, I mean, these character
chameleon
obviously they had,
they had to represent
something different. Um,
and again, I didn't want,
actually there's a line
that a pretty constant says,
yeah, don't make a, you know,
the, the Jayco character when
he just wants to have a baby.
And it just didn't make me the
bastard for wanting to have a baby.
And I sort of felt like quite a lot of
the time that could have come out of
anywhere. Don't make me, don't make it,
don't turn me into an evil person
for doing this. Yes. So, you know,
twice wasn't an evil person,
you know,
the husband wasn't an evil person
because he couldn't love her the way she
needed.
They have a floored it and everybody's,
everybody's got good and bad and they
will just trying to get it right and
getting it very wrong along the way.
It's all winter.
And I both thought of Friends
of ours that are very, like,
what would Tyson's character be like?
People that are really open minded
and you know, like really kind of fun.
They love every wind people that just
kind of, they love everybody, you know?
Yeah.
Embrace.
Yeah. There was a one scene I found
in particular that was quite strong.
It's when Millie opened up to her
scars to Jess and they kind of,
it kind of slowed down the entire movie
kind of slowed down for you to absorb
what was going on. And there was also
in that moment with, with Ken as well,
you know, when, when that was
first revealed, um, how first,
how did it kind of start out? Like, um,
how much makeup did you have to go on
or how did, uh, how did you want it
physically? How did we achieve
that, do you mean? Yeah. Uh,
I don't have very much here.
So it was very easy to strap down
and B flat and,
and then this,
we used to CGI and post to
make it look. Yeah, yeah.
Got It was right. So we, you know,
the company in London would send me
photographs to make sure that it,
cause most CGI companies, they don't do
that kind of work so much. They do more,
you know,
something growing things up and stuff.
So this was just very subtle to look
really natural. And the first time,
uh, the first image that came back,
well took a few rounds to get it right.
Let's just put it down.
But I think it in the end came out
as a very sensitive and you know,
beautiful scene,
which I love that scene I do to your face.
That scene when you look up,
it's just kills when, well,
what kills me is the way he looks
at me. Do you has this thing? Um,
she's such a nice
person. I, and I watched,
I watched her in this movie and
when she's feeling the most pain,
she smiles and the way she looks at,
this is what I think the crux of
the film is between these two women,
the way she looks at Millie and she
smiled at her and accept her when Millie
feels at her lowest kills me every time.
So beautiful.
When she did that smile when we were
on the set, you know, I just kind of,
almost gas because I felt like a laser
beam of love came and I could see it on
the set and on the Monitor I
was like, wow. It was powerful.
You see it in the film. It's
amazing. Yeah, she's a good,
she's a good one.
Strong.
Um,
another theme that was also played
through was the juxtaposition of life and
death.
I was totally expecting for some reason
when Jess was trying to give birth, that,
you know, a million would kind
of die in there and it'd be,
it would just be guessing.
It'd be a bit too much.
Just see both that life and death kind
of go through all at the same time.
But I really appreciated the fact that,
you know,
there was the portion of the scene
where she finally gave birth.
We focused on celebration of life.
We focus on that sort of effort with
everyone in the room and sharing that and
then, you know, did another dedicated
scene where we flashed through uh,
Millie's life and then she kind
of slowly, slowly parts away. Um,
okay.
Yeah, I think it's, you know,
the story's really special.
It's birth death and everything, you know,
birth, death, life, everything in between.
And it's an incredible
that you changed it,
they said to less than two
hours and managed to kind
of really reflect something
very, very real and very human.
It amazes me. Bless you. Well,
you know, maybe with me basically from
the end to know how many, but yeah,
it was, it was very gratifying
to see that, that, that
that's, that sort of working,
you know, for that has, it has an impact.
We got another audience question.
Yep.
Hi. Thank you all for the movie. It
was beautiful. I was here in tears. Um,
my question I guess is
mostly for Tony, um, on this
film and or maybe other films,
you know,
I'm watching you for two
hours and falling apart. Um,
what is it like for your family and
friends to see you in a movie like this or
I'm sure other films to um, to,
to watch her, they used to it or,
um,
is that something,
is it hard for them to see you fall
apart on screen even though you might be
right now?
You know, one of my best friends, I've
known him since I was 13, he said, oh,
it was really,
really hard watching your diet,
but it was a much harder
watching you have sex.
I think my parents felt the same way.
I mean, yeah, it's, I mean,
I found it weird playing someone
who died. I got to of, I mean,
I can't imagine how it is for people
who really know me and love me to watch
that because it's quite realistic.
Yeah.
Um, so how was, uh, how was
it working with the kids?
Not much has been said about that.
It's like
all the, all the, all this serious talk
about like life and death and it's like,
yeah, there are also children here. How
was, how was it working with them so much?
It's
fine. I mean they're just so
free and honest and present.
That's what you want from any actor
that you're working in. Um, but we,
the house that we lived in,
we spent how much time in rehearsal
with them to do that. No week anything.
We basically lived there. We didn't
sleep there, but we spent all day.
Then the meals and yeah,
we had lots of activities and hung
out and we went through scenes.
But it was just,
I think more than anything,
just getting to that comfort level so
that people feel natural and comfortable
and at ease with what they're doing.
I know I'm one of the first days I had
a plan that we would rehearse during
lunch and then I would have you and
Dominic make the lunch for the kids.
I think you guys were
a little bit shocked.
Like the cater isn't bringing lunch
in and I know you're the parents,
you got to make the lunch and the kids
would come up and they didn't like the
food and I'd say go ask your mom,
go ask your dad.
So I was trying to like have little
arrangements where they had to become the
mom and dad, but you know, honor
is the girl is very professional.
And then our little friend,
the boy is like a wild maniac Ryan.
And for example,
member when he puts the honey and the
sister will let discussing that was his
favorite.
He could not wait until we did that and
he every minute do I get to put more
honey on? And then he was
just so excited about that.
And then the worst thing was I didn't
realize he was drinking the honey.
And so by the time she was so hyped up
that he was just bouncing around like
what? Like running around
up and down the stairs.
He had to monitor the amount of sweets he
got to eat. After that I was just like,
if I saw his dad or anybody walking
with a cookie torn when I'm like, no,
take it away. No more sugar. Cause
the guy was, he was a maniac.
He never acted how he, I don't think
he had done like one commercial saying,
you know,
eating probably some honey
some days I saw he was testing your
patients. Tony, I saw him testing yours.
Oh, he'll never, he'll never watch this.
He'll never hear this.
And
I really love, I love him.
I think he did a great job.
That's beautiful to work with. It's very
hard am I think it traditionally that,
that probably feel quite bad
saying this, but the British, um,
Gerald actors and not as
naturalistic sometimes as, as,
as American job actors and I don't know
why that he got some bad ones in America
today. It goes from having these two
really. What, and you know, you, you,
you saw a lot of people for it
and, and, and, and, you know,
even though you knew that, that, that,
that was going to be challenging. It was,
well, I was trying to find
the kid that had, you know,
a lot of life and energy and you know,
rambunctious.
That wasn't like a stage train kit.
So the person we almost hired was so
energetic that he tackled me to the
[inaudible] ground. I was
on the ground. I was like,
whoa.
So this one was like,
that was like def con five and I got a
def con four one is who we ended up with
Ryan.
But he's so natural to what she captured
them just in their own world and it's
perfect. And she's very emotionally
intelligent as well. She was,
she was from another planet.
She is,
oh, we do have another one. Yes.
Um, I really loved the movie.
Thank you very much for coming. Um,
one thing I wanted to ask is, um,
so it's a very recent trend that we see,
uh,
women in their forties or late
thirties as main characters are films.
We're used to seeing them only very young,
as romantic potential romantic
partners of main male characters.
And then you don't see that actor for a
few years and then they suddenly are the
mother. So, um, what a
wonderful trajectory.
So, so yeah, so this is,
I mean I was very happy to see this as
one of the very few movies around as you
know, having women in that. Yeah.
So how do you wish it was a trend?
Yeah, that's what I wanted to be a trend
I think.
Is it that trend?
What role do you think this film
plays in that hopefully a trip.
There is a big conversation going on,
you guys,
I'm sure aware of it that everybody's
talking about. Why aren't there more?
Why are there equal pay for, you
know, male and female actors?
Why aren't there more
wonderful parts for women?
Why aren't there more female directors?
Why aren't there more female writers?
And this is like, uh, you know,
great thing about gender
unconscious gender bias.
I actually understand that you guys have
had training here at Google to really
change that proportion,
that balance and your group is
really an inspiration to us all.
We've been talking about you guys a lot
that we had some people come and gave us
a training workshop that worked with
Google and told us how the culture really
changed here and got more
productive and kind of more awesome.
So we hope that the rest of our industry,
we hope that the film industry learns
a lesson from you guys to have a better
gender balance, you know, but it's
not happening yet. As we know,
the statistics are pretty sad.
It's,
we're actually have the worst report
card of any industry almost, right? Yeah.
The film industry,
you would think we would be more
creative and more forward thinking.
But we love that you guys are
like leading the future, you know,
leading the pathway, you know, and you're,
you're on the right side of history
and you're ahead of the game.
So we want the film industry to be the
same way too. We want to change this.
Okay.
Not just the film industry, the world,
but we only care about the film.
Okay. Well, but if we can tell
stories that encourage, you know,
people of diverse, diverse
voices, every kind of person,
you know, women and men, every,
every nationality, every buddy,
we want that kind of, those voices
out there, you know, I mean, you,
we love orange is the new black
where everybody looks different.
Nobody looks perfect and it's
beautiful and people like it.
So it works when you do it,
you know, people respond.
But how do we get these slow
moving dinosaur, you know,
film studios to change and catch
up with 2015 catch up with Google.
Do you have any, uh, major takeaways
after working on this movie? Like,
did you learn anything from playing your
character is working with other, uh,
other characters and the other actors
she taught us, we learned from these.
He is to, you always learn something.
Hmm.
But I think some of the things that we
all talked about and our friend over here
mentioned, you know, it's like cherishing
those moments in life, you know? And,
and it does make you think when you
meet with a lot of people that are
caretakers and, and people that are, uh,
that are survivors that you do want to
value every moment and make your life
count and make what you do something that
you're proud of and excited about and
you know,
so yeah,
I think it makes us all like empowers
us all to try to do cool shit.
There was that I'm seeing right at the
end where he saw it red on the wall
before I die and then there's
a blank. Um, yeah. Was,
that was an actual thing. I've
never been to London before, but
around the world and like 80 countries
around the world, Candy Chang,
actually she lives in New Orleans.
She's a city planner.
Have you guys heard of this before?
She started this idea and talks
about her idea for creating this.
She's amazing in the, and people can put
them up like you guys could call her up,
she'll send you the kit,
you can put it up on the wall and
everybody can write stuff. And it happens,
happens spontaneously
all around the world.
One day we were driving to the set and I
just saw it out of the corner of my eye.
There was one up there. I'm like, Hey
Tony, do you want to skip lunch today?
And we're going to take the five d
camera over and just film a little scene.
And Tony said, yes. And then Dominic said,
where are you guys going? I want to go,
you know, cause I thought I'll just
have Tony. So we went over there,
we didn't have the DP,
none of the crew,
and we just filled that little cool scene.
That was the one.
It's one of the most,
well that's an example of one of the most
exciting things about working on this
movie.
Catherine is very open and very free.
And the amount of times I would turn up
to work with an idea of what was gonna
happen and that would happen,
but then it would move completely off.
It was so exciting.
It was so exciting to be like,
don't you want to be surprised in life?
You know?
And the film was very,
um,
passionate and uh, and I loved
it, but that was just one,
one thing that just, I didn't know
that was going to happen. You know,
it was really great.
And even like, oh, for example, in
that same taxi scene after them,
the cup incidents,
okay,
then we're driving along in the
taxi and suddenly I'm like, okay,
we're going to do this closeup on drew
and the camera person whispers in my ear,
we don't have any more cards
for the camera. I'm like,
aren't we like on a major motion
picture? Well, indeed picture.
How could we run out
of card to the camera?
And so I didn't really want you guys
to know that we were like amateur hour.
So I'm like,
hey,
why don't we do this park
like selfies on the iPhone?
So I pulled out my iPhone,
let's do this scene like that.
And then of course through,
and Tony did that awesome scene that you
see in the movie that's filmed on the
iPhone five and recorded on the iPhone
vibe we're getting out of London.
Uh,
so that was one of those,
yeah. I was like, Ooh, Shit. What
Cameron? All I've got left is the iPhone,
but it's a very cool scene.
Right?
Because it feels real and it was and yes.
So we try and there's another
scene filmed on the iPhone pipe.
Did anybody figure out what it was?
Come on you guys. Are there any
technical, geeky cause warts at there?
Um,
it was it the birth scene.
I know there was that there's the face
time interaction or not winning. Oh yeah.
Good.
But that wasn't it.
Yeah.
I'm not going to tell we're going to
give a prize. If anybody figures it out,
you're going to get something special
in the mail. It might be a cup. Oh,
this is what we worked for.
You.
Okay.
I bet you didn't put anything on,
on the wall on filling in the blanks.
Oh yeah. Tony and Dominic both rode
on the wall. What did you put a, well,
it says before I die. Dot Dot.
Dot. Before I die. I want it to,
and I wrote fear nothing. And that's
what you see her writing in the movie.
That's amazing. Um, did you guys
want to put anything, uh, when, uh,
when you saw that or would you
of wanting to put something up?
Well then it became a whole exercise
at the end. Credits is the entire wall.
So they spent months creating
things that they would want to tell.
We sat there with a chop
board while we were editing,
like doing the final mix of the movie.
Me and my assistant just wrote like all
the things got people to write all this
stuff by hand. That's the end
credits of the film. I love it.
It's fun.
Well,
it's time to wrap up soon.
So do you have any parting words of advice
for anyone going through life's crazy.
Athens sands is with a best friend.
Keep on trucking,
make them laugh,
try to make them laugh and
see the fun side of it. Yeah.
And for anyone watching here,
the movie will come out in theaters
and two weeks on November six.
Thank you ladies for having us.
I giggle.
Thanks for having us guys.
Yay.
Thank you for all the fun stuff you guys.